so I just re-watched all the John Wick
movies because of the new one and I had
to know just how they did those crazy
stunts how long do they practice is that
really Kiana what would I need to study
to become a master assassin I mean do
they just give Keanu like a fake gun and
say go I want to know what's the
difference between a John Wick fight
scene and all the other fight scenes out
there that don't look nearly as good
according to the director behind the
Citizen Kane of gunfights Chad
stachowski it comes down to essentially
one thing preparation a ton of the
movie's budget often goes to fancy
hotels food and other services that
don't really have to do with the movie
itself forced to halski all that is out
the window he wants to spend all that
cash on being more prepared than anyone
else in Hollywood according to him the
typical three or so weeks people spend
on making fight scenes is ridiculous he
knows of no one who becomes world class
at something in three weeks instead
those fast-paced sequences are prepared
over a period of months if not years the
team behind behind the scenes will beat
up the script until the action beats are
just perfect then they'll design each
and every action sequence over a
painstaking process of violent
brainstorming then the actors trained
for months with not just the best stunt
team out there but actual mercenaries
who do this kind of thing in real life
finally when it comes time for my man
Chad to shoot that scene they have got
it in like five or so days of shooting
of course there's another step after
that that you might be surprised about
all these movies might look so real that
they could basically be a documentary
series about keanu's side gig as a super
assassin but they have a lot more CGI
than you think before I break your heart
showing you the CGI behind the scenes be
sure to like And subscribe real quick
that's what Kiana would do probably okay
so it's super impressive when you see a
really cool CGI alien character like
Thanos or an entire city get destroyed
in an epic CGI battle that's not the
best CGI though no trust me the best CGI
is the CGI you can't even
when you think of the John Wick movies
you think of gritty stunt work not
computer-generated action it's not fast
and furious well guess what the CGI and
the John Wick series is phenomenal the
digital effects team is always working
in the background sometimes literally on
the backgrounds many of the over-the-top
locations in the film that they have
these over-the-top fight scenes in are
actually in front of a green screen
though the shot that truly blew my mind
was when I saw the big Keanu Reeves
motorcycle chase fight from John Wick
chapter 3 was full of CGI Keanu may have
been on a motorcycle but he wasn't
actually racing through New York City
having sword fights at like 80 miles per
hour I mean I'm sure he does that all
the time and is off hours but not in the
movie he's certainly trained enough for
it can you even imagine John Wick with
anyone other than Keanu not really well
that really couldn't have happened
because the way those movies are shot
pretty much require someone with Keanu
Reeves levels of training to do it right
most action movies like this feature
Quick Cuts or special tricks to hide the
stunt performer switching out a John
Wick fight scene keeps the camera on
Wick himself and just pans around with
him as he delivers Carnage left and
right in a ballet of blood and bullets
there's really no way to hide a
stuntman's switch so Keanu Reeves is
doing it like 90 percent of the time
that means he's pretty much got to have
enough skills to be a pro assassin in
real life seriously look at this dude
running through the gun range with Halle
Berry if he ever needed to retire from
acting he could have a legit career as
an assassin that would probably be at
John Wick's level there's no way 90
percent of real world assassins have
this kind of skill as you can see that
requires months of Judo training weapons
training driving training all as prep
work that's just to provide general
knowledge and muscle memory after
watching him do all his training I want
to see him fight Tom Hardy in a real
Judo match 20 bucks on Reeves after he
gets his training down then he has to do
incredible amounts of rehearsal so that
the fights look just right for the
fourth film he had to train for three
months to get all the choreography down
that included learning new skills like
nunchucks and more driving techniques
what's truly insane is that he had to
combine all his skills into one next
level stunt in Paris while driving he's
got to do a reverse 180 drift around the
arc to Triumph reload his gun and then
fire out the door all with the kind of
precision we would expect from Mr Wick I
mean if they let him do all that what
would they not let him do knowing that
Keanu Reeves does 90 of the stunts in
the wick movies makes me want to know
when is it not Keanu Reeves I'm the kind
of fan who watches the Mandalorian and
tries to figure out when the Mandalorian
is actually Pedro Pascal under there
instead of his stunt doubles Brendan
Wayne and Latif Crowder truth be told
it's pretty easy to tell when it's not
Keanu just look at any instant where
John Wick is hit with a car nearly lit
on fire or thrown around excessively
cause while directors may have to have a
panic attack watching Tom Cruise fling
himself and the actual film into
horrible danger Chad stachowski has no
interest in being the guy who offs Keanu
Reeves don't get me wrong he's nothing
but praise for Reeves and his stunt
credit stahowski used to be a stunt guy
one who actually stunted for Keanu
during the Matrix movies and he actually
said when it comes to driving a car
handling a gun or remembering fight
choreography Reeves is actually better
than most Pro stunt performers out there
including himself so he feels pretty
comfortable with Reeves doing all that
dangerous stuff just anytime you see Mr
Wick get thrown off a building wrecking
a car getting stabbed getting slammed
into something or just generally beaten
to a pulp that's probably his stunt
double you don't notice it because that
next level CGI team edits out the stunt
performer's face and puts in Kiana's
that's all well and good but if I was in
one of those dangerous scenes and I
didn't get to work with Keanu I'd be so
mad according to pretty much everyone he
is a joy to work with of course the only
question I really want answered is what
it's like to work with Keanu leaves on
these movies unsurprisingly it seems
like it's pretty awesome Lawrence
Fishburn is the guy most likely to show
up in a Keanu Reeves movie he's seen
Reeves go from Neo from The Matrix all
the way to full Baba Yaga mode as far as
filming the Wix series goes Fishburn
didn't have the best time I mean don't
get me wrong he loves this series and he
loves the Bowery King but making these
movies is apparently super tedious and
slow no wonder he's done so much TV
lately as far as Reeves goes though
Fishburne basically said John Wick
chapter 4 was the most hardcore he's
seen his old kung fu buddy go he said
the Judo Reeves showed off was literally
Next Level that's Kiana's buddy though
how much can we trust his word really
well Donnie Yen it man himself does not
hold back when it comes to his American
movies he recently called out pretty
much all the American films he's done
from Rogue one to even John Wick 4
saying that they all tried to play up
the same stereotypes that he had to put
his foot down about the man bad-mouthed
his own movie right for his release date
so his word is pretty trustworthy he
actually said that his time with Keanu
and Chad stachowski was the best time
he's had on a Hollywood movie if Donnie
yed says that you're a nice guy to work
with you know it's true because he would
definitely tell everyone if it wasn't
if I could live in any action movie
Universe it would 100 be the John Wick
one I want to deal out weird assassin
coins with a bunch of cool tattooed goth
people with creepy names that's the
dream dude